suddenly the candidate who was fading
from view his box office again in
America it was in the suburbs that a
veteran of American politics showed he
has what it takes to win and that the
country might just be ready to believe
him in the space of a week Joe Biden has
gone from no-hoper to frontrunner the
former vice president hitting his stride
on Super Tuesday
we're gonna bring together all Americans
and we did that we showed that last
night regardless your race your gender
whether you have a disability your
ethnicity
Democrats Republicans independents of
every stripe I really mean that this is
what we have to do to win this is what
we have to unify the nation that's why I
entered the race in the first place it
means the front-runner until now knows
he's in a fight Super Tuesday was
sobering for Bernie Sanders this is now
a two horse race so the American people
have got to understand that this is a
conflict about ideas about a record
about a vision for where we go forward
and I like Joe Joe is a decent guy and I
do not want this campaign to degenerate
into a Trump type epoch where we're
attacking each other where it's personal
attacks that is the last thing this
country wants so what was it to turned
America back on to by Bernie's a nut so
I think that you know makes people you
know go towards the moderate candidate I
don't think most people felt Bernie
Sanders had a chance to defeat Trump in
this country Bernie's a bit of a risk
and in terms of drawing in the moderate
vote Michael Bloomberg gambled half a
billion dollars that he could win over
Americans the former mayor of New York
lost the bet and is now backing Biden
[Applause]
for president to defeat Donald Trump and
today I am leaving the race for the same
reason to defeat Donald Trump because
staying in would make it more difficult
to achieve that goal no one was happier
at that than Donald Trump he wasn't even
asked about the election before offering
his analysis
Bloomberg put in probably a billion
dollars and you know sometimes you just
don't have what it takes and I said to
him it's not easy doing what I did is it
Democrats do at least now no they face a
very simple choice between the
grassroots movement of Bernie Sanders
and the establishment credentials of Joe
Biden and at the heart of it one simple
question who do they think is best
equipped to win in November the next two
Tuesday's will see a raft of states add
their votes and they may be decisive
we've seen a game though it is almost
impossible to predict American politics
these days
Gregg Milam Sky News Los Angeles